questa storia parla di sport parla di
sport parla di degrado sociale
dell'urbano ma parla anche di riscatto e
di rivincita
il teatro di questa storia è librino
città attorno alla città
i protagonisti di questa storia sono i
briganti librino è il centro iqbal masih
è il rugby librino è una città che nasce
attorno a catania per essere la città
del futuro
doveva avere videosorveglianza e tutti i
comfort ai servizi possibili e
immaginabili
nella realtà così non è stato a librino
degrado e criminalità si nutrono
vicendevolmente
ma a librino operano anche tante
associazioni che hanno voglia di fare
una di queste del centro iqbal masih che
un centro sociale nel vero senso della
parola dove si svolge un attività di
doposcuola di laboratori musicali e
teatrali tutto portato avanti da
volontari è un giorno questi volontari
si recarono a un supermercato un centro
commerciale per acquistare dei colori e
dei degli album da disegno e si
trovavano di fronte uno di quei cestoni
con le offerte dentro c'erano dei
palloni da calcio da basket pallavolo e
del rugby e lì scattò l'idea è
illuminante quel pallone dalla forma
sana forse era quello che mancava in
quel percorso di formazione dei piccoli
che frequentavano il centro sociale
acquistano tre di questi palloni pur non
avendo nessuno di loro mai giocato a
rugby lo conoscevano e apprezzavano i
valori ma nessuno di loro era mai stato
né giocatore e allenatore né altro
e il pallone diventò il premio il premio
per aver svolto bene i compiti e quindi
finiti fi che il doposcuola si portavano
i ragazzini al campo san teodoro al
campo da calcetto di carne del del san
teodoro per giocare a rugby
fu una magia una magia perché questo
pallone diventò il momento clou della
giornata quindi tutti facevano i compiti
perché devono andare a giocare è
talmente tanto vanno bene che l'anno
successivo si decise di partecipare a un
campionato giovanile under 12 e si formò
una una squadretta che partecipava
appunto a tutti i concentramenti zonali
una squadra che come disse un piccolo
briganti librino intervistato perdeva
sempre ma si divertiva tantissimo
e il messaggio insito nel rugby era
secondo noi e secondo tutti quelli che
lo praticano proprio questo a
prescindere dal risultato o a
prescindere dal valore dell'avversario
si scende in campo e si gioca al massimo
delle proprie possibilità perché così
facendo ottieni già la prima vittoria
il successo fu tale che si decise senza
soldi senza campo senza sponsor di fare
la cosa più logica cioè di rilanciare
cioè non dismettere l'attività ma di
creare una squadra seniores di creare
una squadra che dovesse essere non solo
il punto di arrivo per i piccoli che
iniziavano la loro carriera rugbistica
ma anche una forza trainante del dei
briganti librino briganti che shell sono
un nome non a caso perché diciamo
simboleggiava la voglia di
riappropriarsi di qualcosa che è nostro
ma che nessuno ci vuole dare in questo
caso una casa dopo i primi due anni di
attività
ecco alla creazione della prima squadra
che significava visibilità e liquidità
perché tutti i membri della prima
squadra della squadra seniores
dal presidente all'allenatore ai
giocatori si autotassa
sono per finanziare l'attività dei
briganti dopo il primo anno di attività
succede una cosa a nostro modo di vedere
gravissima
restiamo senza campo il campo san
teodoro viene ristrutturato dal comune
in parte solo il campo di calciotto è
affidato a delle società di calcio
il risultato fu che fummo costretti a
portare i ragazzini in giro per la città
alla ricerca di spazi e questo determina
una grande dispersione di ragazzi con
esiti spesso negativi e qualche volta
purtroppo drammatici tanto per sgombrare
il campo dalle idee che potrebbero
essere non precise lo stiamo parlando di
ragazzini problematici un po strani
stiamo parlando di ragazzi che crescono
in una società che li pone davanti alla
scelta o la scuola se ci vanno o la
strada significa allenare una squadra
all'interno della quale ci sono i
giocatori appartenenti a entrambe le
famiglie che sono state purtroppo
protagoniste dell'ultima fatto di sangue
di librino il l'episodio drammatico che
determinò la svolta dei briganti li
determinò a a un passo molto importante
fu la scomparsa tragica e in circostanze
misteriose di uno dei piccoli dell'under
14 per cui realizzato che essere senza
campo significava perdere il contatto
col territorio si decise il 25 aprile di
due anni fa di andare a liberare una
struttura bellissima all'interno del
quartiere di librino che sta esattamente
di fronte al palazzo di cemento che è il
simbolo della criminalità organizzata
all'interno del quartiere è il 25 aprile
i briganti i volontari del centro iqbal
masih e semplici cittadini o
individualmente o in quanto partecipanti
ad altre associazioni
entrano il san teodoro struttura che
costa di un campo di calciotto un campo
da rugby e due palestre eccezionali
completamente
vandalizzata e nel corso di 13 anni di
abbandono e iniziano un'opera di
recupero a proprie spese della struttura
i ragazzini nelle under che lavorano a
fianco dei grandi
i cittadini del quartiere che lavorano
insieme a tutti per riappropriarsi di
una struttura che doveva essere ed è la
casa dei briganti librino
questa sembra una bellissima favola ma i
momenti di difficoltà sono stati enormi
perché come potete ben intuire non tutti
gradiscono la presenza di qualcosa che
voglia costruire all'interno di una
realtà dove ricostruzione non c'è
veramente niente o quasi poco i continui
furti da quello banale delle merendine e
dei succhi di frutta che dovevano
servire per il terzo tempo di un torneo
dei ragazzini ai furti dei cavi di rame
dell'impianto di illuminazione del campo
appena realizzato ci hanno inizialmente
buttato giù ma nella realtà ci hanno
dato quella spinta ad andare avanti in
maniera assolutamente più energica anche
perché nonostante non ci sia mai stata
dalla ricerca del risultato a tutti i
costi perché per noi il rugby era il
mezzo di trasmissioni di determinati
valori che sono il sostegno la
solidarietà il prendersi le proprie
responsabilità perché il rugby è uno
sport che ti impone di prendere di
assumerti la tua responsabilità di
quello che fai nel bene e nel male
nonostante dicevo non ci fosse stata
questa idea del risultato a tutti i
costi i risultati sportivi iniziavano a
iniziano a vedersi
avete visto la foto di un'azione di
gioco quella un'azione relativa alla
partita di spareggio per la serie b
disputata contro l'amatori catania che
storicamente è stata ed è la società
leader nel rugby isolano vorrei citare
tre esempi importanti dei risultati non
solo sportivi ma diciamo anche formativi
che sono la partecipazione al torneo
topolino con la nostra under 12
l'organizzazione del torneo iqbal masih
è la partecipazione di due nostri atleti
all accademia federale
il torneo topolino è il più importante
torneo italiano di minirugby di rugby
giovanile vede la partecipazione di
diverse migliaia di piccoli atleti e noi
al secondo anno di attività
decidemmo che senza soldi forse l'idea
migliore era quella di portare i nostri
piccoli a partecipare al torneo topolino
ci inventammo una riffa sociale con dei
premi messi in palio donati da amici o
da simpatizzanti e riuscimmo a
raccogliere vendendo biglietti del costo
di 1 euro
un solo euro 3.000 euro nel giro di 20
giorni
raccogliamo tutte le autorizzazioni dei
genitori per portare i bambini a treviso
li portammo a treviso che era un luogo
secondo alcune mamme molto pericoloso
per i loro simili viaggio a treviso con
questi due pulmini con tappa a roma
ospitati da un centro sociale come
quello come l'iqbal masih con gita di
istruzione di sti ragazzini che non
avevano mai visto nient'altro se non
forse un io c'ho a catania
arriviamo a treviso è la prima partita
che ci troviamo di fronte contro il
benetton treviso la squadra più forte
d'italia che ovviamente non voglio
pensar male ma era stata posta contro la
squadra più scarsa di italia
presumibilmente scendiamo in campo e
vinciamo vinciamo
sorprendentemente segniamo per primi e
poi difendiamo questo vantaggio alla
morte è quello fu per noi un trionfo per
altro
entrammo nelle prime 25 squadre d'italia
abbiamo una cosa assolutamente
impensabile il torneo iqbal masih è un
torneo che ai briganti organizzano da
otto anni e che chiude la settimana
contro il lo sfruttamento del lavoro
minorile e che vede
ha visto nell'ultima edizione la
partecipazione di 600 ragazzini della
categoria under 12 under 14 e quest'anno
anche under 10
ecco alla partecipazione di due
selezioni maltesi che hanno dato un
respiro internazionale all'evento
ne parlo perché dalla seconda edizione
il torneo palma si è organizzato dai
briganti e dal centro iqbal masih quindi
in totale autogestione è il torneo
giovanile più importante d italia da
napoli in giù
finalmente l'anno scorso alla
federazione se n'è accorto quindi ora
inizia anche a darci un po di attenzione
l'ultima cosa che voglio segnalarvi è
appunto la partecipazione all'accademia
federale di due nostri atleti che
accademie federali sono delle strutture
che la freddezza ha creato da due anni
ce ne sono nove in italia che
costituiscono il primo passo per la
creazione di giocatori di alto livello
quindi sostanzialmente sono è
l'anticamera della nazionale nel primo
anno di selezione e di vita e
l'accademia siciliana due atleti dei
briganti di primis ea generazione cioè
quelli che hanno iniziato con noi a 89
anni sono stati selezionati hanno
giocato uno di queste anche partecipato
giocando da titolare a una selezione
delle accademie quindi sostanzialmente
in nazionale io chiudo qui dicendovi
semplicemente una cosa credo che se si
ha la forza di portare avanti le proprie
idee per quanto difficili possano
sembrare alla fine un risultato buono si
ottiene